what's going on guys this is Rob if you
guys enjoy my content make sure you hit
the subscribe button and make sure you
hit that little bell so you never miss
out on my sexy voice
okay so getting into Doomsday Clock kana
this this is kind of a slow bill but it
is really starting to pick up we've got
about four more issues and at the end of
this is like something really really big
happens which is kind of cool but this
initially picked up with Lois Lane and
Clark Kent
inside the Daily Planet now the way the
Geoff Johns start this is the source is
really kind of like Lois Lane getting
yelled at you know for a story and
nothing really crazy nothing bonkers
from what we would normally expect to
see with regards to what goes on in the
Daily Planet between Lois Lane Perry
White Clark Kent you know the various
reporters but in the middle of all this
we end up finding out the firestorm
Ronnie Raymond is in Russia fighting his
arch-nemesis hos are now the reason why
this matters is because this ties in to
the Superman theory but those guys who
are who are kind of jumping into this in
Doomsday Clock one of the things that
Geoff Johns is established is that
there's this theory that's circulating
around the world very very fast that
various metahumans are basically
american-made that most metahumans 90%
of them in fact exist inside the United
States and so the argument is the United
States government is creating metahumans
now for the most part this isn't really
the case
I mean various characters like killer
frost or a byproduct of experiments gone
wrong
but for the most part most metahumans
don't seem to be like part of a
government conspiracy or anything like
that it just happens to be them in some
form of fashion they're tied in to some
government project or something like
that but we know Superman is from a
different planet we know that that
people like Ronnie Raymond or the
results of an experiment gone wrong we
know that that that these characters are
not tied into the Superman theory and
Ronnie Raymond has publicly denounced
this time and time again but really kind
of like leads the battle directly
against Russia and the reason why is
because what the Russian government's
been doing is implementing metahuman
laws and what this basically means is
that babies and various people are being
tested for a metahuman gene and if they
test positive they're being taken into
custody and no real questions are being
asked at the other half of this is that
Russia has been drumming up anti
metahuman hysteria really like feeding
on the fear of its own people and so the
result of this is that the the Russian
people are very much against metahumans
so when Ronnie Raymond shows up they
immediately turn against him and the
result is that when he's essentially
knocked down by pose arc he's surrounded
by all these various you know people
protesters so on and so forth and the
result that he kind of lashes out and
turns them all to glass now for the
character of Ronnie this can be brought
about by a couple different explanations
two main explanations the first is that
is a byproduct of his ability to
transmute matter which is the most
likely explanation here the other
part of this could just be extreme heat
that is literally he let off such an
astronomical amount of heat that these
folks all turned to glass now in truth
you're talking about something that
you're not somebody to be equivalent to
a nuclear explosion so the fact that
there are still like building standing
and like the entire place is not totally
incinerated is an indication that of
course it's just the transmutation of
matter but what this does is to everyone
watching it makes it look like Ronnie
Raymond killed all these people
they're firestorm in American superhero
flew to Russia and then killed all these
various people it gives the Russian
arguments credence is what it does so of
course this leads to Ronnie Raymond flee
now what we end up having a Superman
who's watching the entire thing unfold
who leaves a Daily Planet and travels to
conduct and this is kind of a cool a
cool moment here now for the character
of Black Adam because what I'm about to
say next I want to go ahead and kind of
you know kind of instill this in you
guys black out has been around since
1945 he's been around for a very very
long time but black Adam and magneto
are very very similar in this regard
there is what I set why state when Black
Adam would show up is because somebody
would be half listening and just be like
he's nothing like magneto man you know
came way after black out here what are
you talking about this of course he did
I know he did but the fact remains with
with black Adam and magneto they're very
very similar in this regard when it
comes to the way when it comes to black
Adam while he is contentedly considered
a villain it's really only one of these
things were like he'll fight against you
if there's a legitimate threat to
conduct that's where his loyalties lie
do not attack him he will not attack you
not only that what what black Adam had
basically done was over the doors of
conduct to those individuals who were
looking to find an escape from general
society because what does Superman
theory being so popular what this means
is that a lot of people are signing
against it like a lot of people are
signing against metahumans and with them
siding against metahumans it's given
metahumans reason to fear for their
lives and so finding some place to flee
conduct was opened up as a safe refuge
if source now here's the other important
thing to Lois Lane had basically
received this package you know that kind
of came out of nowhere with a USB Drive
and when she plugged it in this USB
Drive contains information about the
Justice Society of America and Lois Lane
has no idea who that is
now we know this because with what's
going on what we've seen so far
dr. Manhattan to change things right
like dr. Manhattan and move the lantern
out of the way so Alan Scott never
became the Green Lantern in fact died
before that could happen we know things
like like John
Thunder was you know like he was a hero
at one point he's basically largely been
forgotten the Justice Society of America
has long since been forgotten by people
and is basically Geoff Johns and DC's
way of explaining why we haven't really
seen them since the new 52 I mean we got
earth to but that's the different that's
a whole different version of Heroes this
is a different version of Jay Garrick is
a different version of Superman the
whole nine yards the JSA as we know them
which is to say the team that people
remember from before the new 52 back
during the 90s during the 80s and way
before the 80s or so on and so forth
that teams been gone for a long time and
so while they are making their return
what this does is it establishes the JSA
did exist which means the question
becomes if they existed and there's
there's actual documented evidence of
their existence then why doesn't anyone
remember them why don't people like
Hawkman remember being part of the JSA
because Hawkman still alive so why don't
why don't they remember why does it
remember being part of the JSA why are
those memories gone no we can largely
assume that feeds into like the 10 years
lost from everyone but unless the JSA
only existed during those 10 years did
we have to believe they existed
beforehand which means that they've been
wiped away from the minds of everyone
something that seemingly only dr.
Manhattan would really be able to pull
off and so again it's really kind of
thickening the plot basically bringing
back a lot of these older characters
establishing who they are what they're
about but also saying like they were
here once so where are they now and so
again we don't care just like Jay
Garrick is stuck inside the Speed Force
we know that like Allen Scott doesn't
exist we know different things like that
but like for the other members who were
out there the other characters you know
who were who were part of this whole
thing you know where are they our man
and and so on and so forth you know so
what is it going on here if Superman
goes to locate Ronnie Raymond only to
find out that his powers are basically
running amok to a degree they're really
kind of going a little bit bonkers and
we're assume as it would kind of talk
Ronnie Raymond down and have him work
alongside professor Stein and basically
translate this kid back to its normal
human form after having been turned to
glass this kind of feeds into the nature
of Superman's character now this is very
very important because when it comes to
Superman and DC Comics he's not so much
a father figure for the various
superheroes so much as he is kind of
like the penultimate hero right like the
leader of it all they're kind of the guy
who kind of inspired everybody else to
become a hero as one of the cures they
kind of look up to but this is Geoff
Johns establishing the nature of
Superman kind of reminding us where
Superman's about because this will
probably become important later on when
we end up never we having the fight
between Superman and dr. Manhattan it
was kind of a cool little thing here
because when this kid gets changed back
what it does is it sets in motion the
idea that
Bonnie Raymond consent everybody else
back to normal back in Russia and
civilians of traveling back there of
course Superman arrives first and this
is a very important thing because when
Superman shows up here our initial
inclination might be okay well you got
Vladimir Putin who's existing you order
the current guy in in in Russia you know
right in the show and and then it's like
okay Superman shows up well clear
they're gonna go in to attack him no
they're not and that's a very important
thing because Superman is a hero who's
beyond reproach
you know his stance where he resides
that's that is beyond contestation
everyone knows Superman is a protector
of Earth he's a savior of Earth no one
questions his loyalty no one questions
his role he is definitively a good guy
and when he shows up here and the other
members of the superhero community in
Russia and tend to attack human Vladimir
Putin steps in it says absolutely not
Superman's a good guy Subban is
definitively a good guy but with
Superman showing up what he basically
does is say look the whole incident was
Robert Ronnie Raymond with firestorm
this is an accident it's one that can be
undone and when he makes this statement
it is okay well then let's see what the
guy has to say now the funny thing about
this is that Batman's watching the whole
event unfolding Batman as he's talking
to suit man his response is do not pick
Assad do not make a definitive
declaration and that's the important
thing to bear in mind here this whole
thing is called the Superman theory for
a reason that it all hinges on the idea
that it all started with Superman right
like Superman was the first hero first
superhero to operate out of you know
beta seemingly operate out of earth
released the most popular to operate out
of out of the United States as so the
result is that it all kind of centers
around him for him to make a declarative
statement the Superman theory is false
the Superman theory is wrong the
demonization of metahumans is wrong is
to pick Assad is to basically say anyone
who is in favor of the Superman theory
is incorrect the problem is they don't
have enough information here and that's
why Batman really takes his stance and
says do not pick a side because you
could be wrong and if you're wrong
you're gonna have egg on your face
and if you're wrong people are gonna
look you they're gonna point the finger
as they see it even Superman doesn't
really know what's going on like he's
he's clueless like the government's just
that secretive just that dark and
manipulative but that man keeps harping
on him do not pick a side do not pick
your side do not pick your side Ronnie
Raymond shows up and says look I can fix
everyone I can set everything back to
normal
one of the soldiers pulls a trigger
fires a shot in Ronnie oh you never have
a Superman kind of jumps in the way
protects him but Ronnie Raymond is
attacked by pros are and then in the
middle of it it really all seems to pop
off and that's why
this whole thing has one of big reasons
why that man said do not pick a side
because disel and this will inevitably
lead to a conflict and if it does then
it will be spun news companies exist to
sell themselves facts be damned
they exist to sell themselves by any
means necessary
and they'll suspend the story however
they have to in order to sell themselves
and so that's why this this whole thing
is a huge crapshoot because the way this
looks is Ronnie Raymond basically killed
a whole bunch of people by turning them
into glass Superman shows up and says
not only is can this be reversed is it
you know are you guys wrong for
demonizing Ronnie Raymond the Superman
Theory's false Ronnie Raymond shows up
all hell breaks loose Superman takes
sides against the Russians it looks like
the United States government is acting
against the Russian government it looks
like metahumans are trying to destroy
people who disagree with them that's how
it appears and in this instance Ronnie
Raymond begins to basically start
snapping ready because it's kind of lose
his mind began basically powering up
letting off this energy and what is up
having his Batman charms in a Superman
you have to stop energy levels are
spiking
Superman's idea is that Ronnie Raymond
is powering up and Ronnie Marion is
about to destroy everything and the
response of Batman is it's not Ronnie
Raymond and that's what were met with
this massive surge of blue light and
everything's gone serially dr. Manhattan
has stepped in now we don't know what
role dr. Manhattan's taking here all we
know is that at this moment
dr. Manhattan is chosen to make his move
and we have to wait until February to
find out which such will that being said
guys we're gonna bring this video to an
end if you are new here to come this
explain make sure you guys are the sub
button to become part of the Rob core if
you guys enjoy this video make sure you
drop a like and I will catch you all
later peace
you
you